[Music]
a very good morning to you it's seven
o'clock here in the uk you're very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news it's taken a while
776 days to be exact for the prime
minister to reveal how he's going to
in his words fix the crisis in social
care today we'll hear how the government
plans to do it and why so many mps
just aren't happy with it plus are we
heading for another covered fire break
the vaccines minister nadeem zahawi on
the programme very shortly also on the
programme the former u.s national
security adviser john bolton what does
he make of the afghan withdrawal we'll
find out and the final countdown one of
london's most famous landmarks big ben
is close to completion after a mammoth
restoration to give it a new face
and
david badil is back on tour with his
acclaimed stand-up show trolls not the
dolls david badil touring at last after
his one-man show had to be rescheduled
because of the pandemic it's tuesday the
7th of september
fixing social care but at what cost with
one senior conservative calling the pm's
plans a sham with national insurance
expected to rise to pay for it
i'm live in downing street as the prime
minister prepares to tell his cabinet
taxes will have to rise to pay for
reform of social care
and i'm here in calais after another
record number of migrants crossed the
english channel we'll be asking what
more the authorities could do
with more hot weather expected
michael k williams the star of the wire
and boardwalk empire has been found dead
at his home aged 54 we'll look back at
his career
joy and disbelief we hear from a mother
whose three-year-old son was found alive
after three days alone
in the australian outback
[Music]
the fairy tale goes on britain's emma
radukanu upsets the odds and makes it to
the quarter-final of the u.s open
[Music]
morning everybody
776 days ago the prime minister made a
big promise to fix the crisis in social
care we've now heard the first details
of how he plans to do that with more
coming later a cap will be set on what
people
actually pay for their own care we
understand that will be fixed at just
over 80 000 pounds many mps though
aren't happy one senior conservative
call the plans a sham with money raised
through an increase in national
insurance john craig reports
the last chance saloon perhaps for
reform of social care funding critics
claim it's long overdue
but after attending a house of commons
reception ahead of a plan by boris
johnson to fund social care by raising
national insurance many conservative mps
are complaining it's a 10 billion pound
tax rate that breaks a manifesto promise
we are absolutely committed to bringing
forward plans on adult social care we
set that out in our manifesto and we're
going to do that
as well as a social care shake-up the pm
is also promising cash to clear the
massive nhs backlog caused by covid
which has seen waiting lists saw to over
5 million my government will not duck
the tough decisions needed to get nhs
patients the treatment they need and to
fix our broken social care system says
the pm
but senior tory mps claim raising
national insurance by about one and a
quarter per cent to fund social care
could cost typical workers around 250
pounds a year or five pounds a week
someone earning 30 000 pounds in my
constituency of roslindale and darwin
maybe working in a supermarket or you
know working in a in a school pays a
higher proportion of their income in
national insurance than someone earning
a quarter of a million pounds in the
city of london it sets north against
south it sets young against the old
the reason has been such a row over
using national insurance contributions
to fund social care is that it would
break a promise in the conservatives
2019 election manifesto it couldn't be
clearer on page 15 it says we promise
not to raise the rates of income tax
national insurance or vat this is a tax
guarantee that will protect the incomes
of hard-working families across the next
parliament
those who work in social care say more
funding is urgently needed however
every day millions of people are not
getting the social care that they have a
right to and this affects all of us
today after a cabinet meeting the prime
minister will leave downing street for a
common showdown with his rebellious mps
before a news conference with the
chancellor and health secretary in an
attempted show of cabinet unity
john craig sky news
joining me now is the government
minister nadim zahawi
always a pleasure thank you for joining
us on the program this morning um i know
that you're not going to tell me what
the details are of the plan and you'll
say i'll have to wait to hear what the
prime minister has to say
i can ask you though will it fix the
problem
well i think um successive governments
have um attempted to come forward with
plans and have never quite delivered i
think this prime minister
is determined um to actually
fix the broken social care system now
you can't address the social care system
in isolation because you need to make
sure that integration between
health and social care is completed so
uh you have to also make sure that the
nhs has the funding it needs to be able
to
fix the the sort of the shorter term
difficulty of the pandemic which is why
last night we announced an additional
5.4 billion for this six months on top
of the six point six billion for the
previous six months of additional
spending uh to allow the nhs to make uh
a real dent into that uh backlog the
five million that john craig does
describe in uh the backlog and of course
we estimate about seven million people
haven't come forward and i would urge
them to also come forward uh for
uh their operations it's really
important you know we we put one billion
into uh dealing with the backlog in the
last six months
of elective surgery we've doubled that
two billion on the announcement
yesterday so you've got to do both
things you've got to make sure the nhs
has the funding it needs to deal with
the cost of covert and of course
enhanced hospital discharged that's uh
getting an additional just under 500
million
and of course what the prime minister
will announce to parliament and i think
it's right that he does that in
parliament and then there's a press
conference with him and the chancellor
and the secretary of state for health up
later on today to give the details on
how
uh the social care system uh that so
does require reform one in seven people
k pay over a hundred thousand pounds for
their social care if you have assets of
more than twenty three thousand three
hundred fifty pounds um then your
your social care costs can be absolutely
um
backbreaking so it has to be dealt with
and i think this prime minister will not
shirk
that responsibility and he will set out
his plans today
and in answer to my question
so your question around social care how
are we going to whether the question was
will it fix the problem it was a very
straightforward question well i think
look you know as i said i think you have
to at least have a really good go and
make sure you fix the problem the social
guest is still not necessarily then
well
it would be presumptuous and i think
completely arrogant to say of course uh
katie will fix the problem uh he had a
ready-made deal ready to go two years
ago on the steps of dining street well
no
right so there's two different things
it's really important your the the right
thing to do is to deliver the reform of
social care and the investment into
social care
you've got to make sure then that is
operationalized as we did with the
vaccination program you know
when i came on your programmer when i
took on this role
let's deal with vaccination later on in
the in the conversation let's just deal
with whether or not this is going to fix
the problem that labor says it's not
they say it's only going to benefit
three to five percent of people who need
it
well
i think actually when you see the
details of what the president will set
out you'll see that this is a primary
serious about fixing the problem i'm
just being respectful and cautious in
that you know and and not being arrogant
to say of course yeah yeah everything
will be fixed in five minutes it won't
both in terms of the backlog we'll
tackle it we want to reduce it but it
will increase before it gets better but
we're putting the resources the money
that we announced yesterday the
additional 5.4 billion taking the total
by the way for this year alone of
additional support to the nhs to 34
billion pounds
will go some way to addressing the
backlog in the same way i'm not going to
be arrogant
the amount of money twice you've talked
about the amount of money that's going
to the nhs 5.4 billion which was
announced yesterday the health
foundation says to drop in the bucket
and the nhs needs at least 17 billion
pounds to sort out that backlog
well the 5.4 billion is for this six
months there was 6.6 billion in the
previous uh six months
so more forthcoming if necessary that's
it well as as i say it's really
important that we we deal with both the
nhs getting the funding it needs and
yeah my specific question is whether
there'll be more money forthcoming for
the nhs if necessary
if necessary of course we will continue
to look at what the nhs is because
you've got to fix both you you can't fix
social care without having an nhs that
is actually fit for purpose of course of
course i get that and you know you're
making a pledge today on to my viewers
on the program um
national insurance you said as a party
in the manifesto would not increase and
yet it looks as though that's what
you're going to do are you completely
comfortable with that
well let's wait and see what the details
uh that we set out by the prime minister
you're going to have to get it from
somewhere you said that you're not going
to put up national insurance as part of
the manifesto would you be comfortable
if the prime minister decided that was
the only way to pay for this social care
well i don't want to preempt the prime
minister or speculate i'm just saying if
that's what happened would you be
comfortable with breaking a manifesto
promise but let's wait and see what the
premises set out the important thing is
to remember feel about making a
manifesto promise though
well look i i want to meet every single
manifesto promise that we make that's
the right thing to do
we have gone through an unprecedented
shock to the economy because of the
global pandemic and we've had to deal
with it and make some really really
tough decisions but i don't want to
preempt uh what the prime minister will
announce or what the chancellor
will say in the press conference later
on today very happy to come back on your
show and discuss how we're going to pay
for it the important thing to remember
is that this prime minister will set out
the plan that i think will finally after
successive governments attempting to do
this and failing this prime minister
will actually deal with this and deliver
the funding that will uh fix the the
broken social care system that many many
people even if that means breaking
manifesto promises what about the triple
lock for pensions um that was another
manifesto promise i believe that that
would stay in place are you going to
break that promise too
well first of all
no one is in the business of wanting to
break any promises there's been
if you look at
the triple lock that's been in place and
it's been in the manifesto
the chancellor will set out any spending
plans it would be absolutely
premature and i think wrong for the
minister for vaccine deployment to be
setting out the government today
minister you're not here as the vaccine
minister you're representing the
government today i'm putting it to you
on behalf of my viewers that many of
them voted for your party because you
made those manifesto promises i'm asking
you are you comfortable i'm not asking
you what the prime minister is going to
say i'm going to i'm asking you are you
comfortable with breaking two manifesto
promises potentially i'm not comfortable
breaking any manifesto promises what i'm
saying to you k is that whatever we do
in terms of the finances of this country
and getting the country back on its feet
as the chancellor has done 407 billion
has gone into that safety net to protect
the economy
eight billion into welfare the
chancellor will set out our spending
plans and we'll explain how we're paying
for the social care reforms that we'll
introduce
which will finally i hope begin that
that's a road to dealing with the fish
care problems that we have faced for
many many uh years not decades got it uh
talk to me about an area that you're
much more comfortable with and that is
um
vaccines the eye newspaper reporting
this morning that the government is
planning an october fire break
if
hospital admissions stay high is that
something that you would endorse
so
the vaccines have actually allowed us to
reach a an equilibrium with the uh virus
in the sense that they have prevented
over 100 000 deaths
um many many millions of of infections
and of course hospitalization as well uh
the upward pressure on infections is as
obviously we've reopened uh uh the
economy to uh you know
pretty much uh as close to normal as you
can get
but but obviously schools
no hold on a second so so the the
booster program that we've had the
interim advice from the jcbi on is my
absolute priority that will protect the
most vulnerable to serious infection
that will actually help us to transition
this virus from pandemic to endemic
status the important thing is we get
that right because i think if we do that
well we can continue on this sort of
one-way road towards sustaining the
opening of the economy and by next year
hopefully transitioning this virus from
pandemic to endemic and dealing with it
on an annual basis the thing to do is to
remain cautious let me try this one then
let me try this one let me try this one
suggestions that school half term could
be extended from one to two weeks
because those pesky little biters are
the one that keeps spreading this virus
is that a good idea
so i think the the the right thing is
that we open schools we've opened them
well
with the really comprehensive testing
program and we want to make sure they
stay open and the way you do that is by
protecting the most vulnerable which
like my focus is on the booster program
i don't want to
adjust the half term or go back to any
form of lockdowns because the that's the
worst thing i can we can do to the
economy and to people's livelihoods the
way to deal with them not ruling it out
let me ask you about the migrants
crossing the channel yesterday we were
contacted by the home office last night
telling us that it wasn't a thousand
migrants crossing the channel so they
obviously know how many it was can you
tell us this morning
no what i can tell you though is that
well we are working
with the french authorities they've uh
increased the number of patrols and of
course uh they're doubling the number of
police and enhancing the technology but
in the long term it is the uh
nationality and borders bill
that i think will make a real difference
which again this government is the
government not to shirk this
responsibility it's a tough challenge
you you know it's a tough challenge but
we are dealing with it and that
nationality and borders bill absolutely
lays the foundations for dealing with
this issue uh in the longer term in a
sustainable way but we're working with
the french authorities to make sure that
uh the shorter term uh fixes are also
enhanced as much as we can
do we know what nationalities these
people are
very varying nationalities as you know
from many many
i
uh
uh
if only if there might be afghanis and
whether we would treat them differently
well as you know the prime minister and
the uh foreign secretary gave a
comprehensive statement uh two
statements to to parliament on the work
that we're doing to
continue to enhance what was an
incredible evacuation program of 15 000
people
in uh about a fortnight which is uh
a testament we paid the french
authorities 54 million pounds to deal
with the situation um on to try and stop
migrants crossing the channel it was a
record number yesterday if you can't
give me the number
some suggesting a thousand you're saying
as a government it's less than that but
you can't tell me how many as i said we
paid the french 54 million to manage the
situation um and this was a record
number are we getting value for money
well i think the the work that the
french authorities are
doing is
incredibly important i think it's right
to continue to enhance that and the
conversations we've had
with them
is uh to to really sort of
hold them to account
on the enhanced
measures that they will be thinking
doubling uh the number of police and
increasing the
ability of the tech to help
that is the short-term fix the much
longer term fix is through the
nationality and borders bill which
and we've got a record number of people
crossing the channel yesterday um is
that a yes or no for value for money
that we've given the money to the french
i think we we have to continue to look
at um you're not saying no are you
you're not saying yes
what i'm saying is we have to hold them
to account we've gone uh uh
to our colleagues to say you know how we
uh doubling the number of police
officers how we enhancing the technology
how we dealing with this in the short
term but in the longer term it is uh
through our legislative uh system that
we can introduce as we have done just
like social care this prime minister did
not shirk the responsibility in order to
home secretary to deliver the
nationality and borders bill that will
uh ultimately in the long term deal with
this and
i know you've got to go i know you've
got to go and talk to other people um
i'm starting to get a bit of a complex
because you never come in the studio to
talk to me i will do you know what i
said this morning that i'd like to come
to the studio but i was told it's easier
to do it on online
next interview
it's just as easy to come in i'll make
you a cup of tea you can use my office
to do other interviews
i will i will happily take you up on
that kate great next time um i i'm
looking forward to seeing you here thank
you very much indeed as always mr sahar
we thank you
uh our europe correspondent adam parsons
is in calais for us this morning hello
to you adam a very good morning to you
um so
we don't know how many people crossed
the channel and we don't know whether
we're getting value for money from the
french
yeah that seems to be the sort of clear
message you just got there and i think
we're going to get more people crossing
the channel today because you look out
there that is the english channel this
is song gap beach on the edge of calais
and the water looks pretty calm the
weather is warm and you put those
ingredients together and what you end up
with is a good day for trying to cross
that treacherous stretch
of water treacherous because if i just
back over there you see there's another
ferry
heading out across this stretch of water
a lot of big boats it is the biggest
busiest shipping lane uh in the world
it's also a vast long coast we've seen
helicopters going above us today we were
driving around earlier seeing french
police who are on patrol around here but
this goes on for
a long long way 54 million pounds uh
maybe a good amount of money
to throw at the french police but it's
not going to pay for everything they
need to do here that is their contention
that they don't have uh the resources to
simply monitor
all of this up and down france also says
well it gets more uh migrants than the
uk
uh it has uh that it effectively has a
bigger problem
to deal with and of course not all of
these people going across the channel
are illegal migrants many of them are
going to claim asylum some of them will
be
successful so
this remains a contentious problem the
number of people crossing there we think
it was a record yesterday i haven't seen
anybody trying to make a crossing today
of course they generally do make
themselves quite serious quite invisible
we will wait to see how many people
arrive in britain okay adam for now
thank you live in calais for us this
morning live of course down
on the uh kent coast as well coming up
in the next hour here on sky news also
still to come the smp pushing back
against the government's proposed
increase to national insurance we'll
speak to in blackfoot that's at 8 20
this morning half past nine we'll be
speaking to a comedian ahead of the
reschedule releasing his brand new
one-man show recognizing him of course
there he is david badil
and the golden girls are back speaking
to team gb's two bmx gold medalists
bethany shriver
and charlotte worthington at 9 30.
before that michael k williams the star
of the wire and boardwalk empire has
been found dead at his home at the age
of just 54 his most iconic on-screen
character was omar little in the wire
and the kind that put my gun on no
citizen
you are a morrow
are you not
you are feeding off the violence and the
despair of the drug trade you're
stealing from those who themselves are
stealing the lifeblood from our city
you are a parasite who leeches off just
like you culture of drugs excuse me what
i got the
we shotgun the briefcase
it's on the game though right
for me it was chalky white in boardwalk
empire that um when i think about him
that's the character that i think about
shingi maruiki has more for us this
morning at sky cinema hello to you um
you're too young to remember some of
those characters but it was a
sensational actor he was
morning k yes michael k williams was
perhaps best known for his role in the
iconic critically acclaimed hbo drama
the wire he played the character of of
the character of omar little an openly
gay stick-up man the likes of which we
had never really seen before and that
won him a legion of admirers including
the then presidential candidate barack
obama who called him his favorite
character in his favorite tv show beyond
that he was well known for his role in
that prohibition period drama boardwalk
empire he also starred in the
award-winning 12 years a slave and
overnight a number of tributes have come
pouring in for those unique talents and
that unique ability he had on stage
first one i have here is from his
co-star in the wire wendell pierce who
played the baltimore detective bunk
moorland he said he's an immensely
talented man with the ability to give
voice to the human condition portraying
the lives of those whose humanity is
seldom elevated until he sings their
truth and then we have another one from
the award-winning director spike lee he
said our brother passed away today in
his home the people's republic of
brooklyn he then went on to add our
greats are leaving us left and right god
bless williams found his flat in
brooklyn about 2pm yesterday new york
time a number of media outlets are
saying that the new york police
department are looking into it as a as a
suspected drug overdose but that has not
yet been confirmed it would be an
incredibly sad set of circumstances
though for someone who had spoken so
openly about overcoming an addiction to
drugs and overcoming a difficult
childhood circumstances are still
somewhat to be determined but this is
the incredibly sad loss of a talented
actor who had so much more to give
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
what a great actuaries was you remember
sometimes you could see that big scar on
his face much more uh clearly and
apparently i was reading about it this
morning that was from a bar brawl when
he was in his 20s a great big scar right
down his face as a result of a fight
sadly
he has died overnight at the age of just
54 much much
too early
looking at the coronavirus figures for
you here in the uk this morning there
have been a further 41 000 new cases in
the latest 24 hour period that means
they've now been 7 million kobe cases in
the uk since the pandemic began further
45 people have died in the
uh 28 days since getting a positive test
that number now 133
2274. nearly 23 000 first doses of
recovery vaccine were given yesterday
more than 73 000 people received their
second dose almost 43 and a half million
people are now fully vaccinated though i
was reading this morning that 20
of people under 40 have still not had
their first dose of the vaccine
let's tell you what's happening with the
prince charles clarence house has said
that the prince has no knowledge of an
alleged cash for honours scandal the
prince's former royal valet michael
fawcett has stepped down as chief exec
of the princess foundation after
accusations he promised to help secure a
knighthood and british citizenship for a
saudi billionaire donor
the former brazilian world cup winner
pele has undergone successful surgery to
remove a tumor from his colon the
eight-year-old regarded by some as the
greatest footballer of all time thanked
fans and doctors on social media after
the operation at a hospital in sao paulo
on saturday
there he is
we wish him a speedy recovery of course
now opposition politicians in myanmar
have announced a public revolution
against the hunter which took power in
january urging people in every part of
the country
to revolt let's speak to our south asia
correspondent siobhan robbins who's
standing by for us this morning hello to
you she won a very good morning to you
tell us more
yes so today we've seen the acting
president of the energy which is the
opposition government announcing this
defensive war as you say asking people
across myanmar to join the revolt so
what does that really mean well actually
since the military's seized a power in
february we've seen widespread violence
more than a thousand people killed by
security forces and since april or may
time we've seen various different groups
rising up against the junta so we've
seen people's defense forces
organizing themselves in towns in cities
we've seen attacks bomb attacks against
uh military positions and we've also
seen ethnic armed groups join the fight
against the junta as well so what we
aren't going to see is shiny new tanks
from the opposition driving into napier
door they simply don't have that kind
type of
firepower what we will possibly see
though is people across the country
being inspired to join existing
resistance we might see further attacks
uh in the cities as well as more joined
up fighting between people's defense
forces and ethnic armed groups i think
the the concern here is that this is
going to extend the bloodshed in myanmar
because we have seen that the military
for decades now uh doesn't mind using
strong power and repression against the
people in order to keep control we
haven't seen any really decisive
intervention from the international
communities so the opposition government
will be hoping that they can get some
sort of support from outside that they
can get some sort of legitimacy from
outside and that the people inside
myanmar will rise up and continue to
rise up on mass okay thanks so much
indeed thanks a lot siobhan coming up in
just a few moments time we'll be
speaking to the former u.s security
adviser john bolton he'll be with us
here in the studio so do stay tuned for
that meantime look at these cool pics
when you're out on the open sea you
might expect to see some marine life but
how close of an encounter was that my
goodness mia kayaker in puerto madrid in
argentina got up close and personal with
a whale while out for a paddle oh my
goodness may you be nervous weren't you
the southern right whale which can be
found in much of the southern hemisphere
seemed very curious about its visitor
but unafraid
the mammal which is about four times the
length of the kayak was in a playful
mood swimming beneath and splashing with
its fins and also with its tail how
fabulous are those pictures um let's
talk to you about climate change though
should we given that we're looking at
those pictures just at the moment and
this is our climate dashboard i think
most of you are familiar with this for
now but for those that aren't let me
just break it down for you um a lot of
numbers to start with very
straightforward when you know what
they're showing uh the top line shows
how the uk's power is produced so today
24 of our power is from nuclear and you
can see how much warmer the earth is now
in the second line since 1880 when
modern records
began 1.23 degrees warmer the next line
well that is the figure to how long
scientists believe it will take to reach
the plus 1.5 degrees celsius figure seen
by many as a point of no return for the
planet only 11 years away say scientists
unless we do something about it right
now
the one at the bottom massive number
isn't it and that
is the total amount of co2 emissions in
millions
of tons
my goodness
and you can keep up with all of the
stories affected by the global climate
on the daily climate show right here
live on sky news every weekday at 6 30
p.m
if you weren't with us in the last half
hour i can tell you that we had with us
the vaccines minister nadeem zahawi he
told me the government can't guarantee
to fix the social care system even with
a massive cash injection he was speaking
as boris johnson prepares to unveil his
plans for social care which are believed
to include an increase in national
insurance contributions for workers and
employers
you have to at least have a really good
go and make sure you fix the problem the
social guess is still not necessarily
then well
it would be presumptuous and i think
completely arrogant to say of course uh
katie will fix the problem i'm asking
you are you comfortable i'm not asking
you what the prime minister is going to
say i'm going to i'm asking you are you
comfortable with breaking two manifesto
promises potentially i'm not comfortable
breaking any manifesto promises what i'm
saying to uk is that whatever we do
in terms of the finances of this country
and getting the country back on its feet
as the chancellor has done 407 billion
has gone into that safety net to protect
the economy
eight billion into welfare the
chancellor will set out our spending
plans and we'll explain how we're paying
for the social care reforms that we'll
introduce
tomorrow cohen uh joining us from dining
street this morning hello to you
tomorrow he's dancing on the head of a
pin there wasn't he
good morning k yes he certainly was now
the message from boris johnson today kay
is that previous governments have ducked
the tough decisions needed to fix the
social care system but he is going to do
it and people may not like some of the
detail but he's going to push it through
and he will be telling his cabinets who
are meeting round the table for the
first time since covid today how that is
going to work and we know it is going to
involve tax rises that many in his party
don't like now how they're going to fix
the system as he puts it is by
introducing a cap on how much any one
person will pay for their care if they
have dementia or another life limiting
condition and i can tell you k that cap
is going to be over 80 000 pounds which
is a win for the chancellor because
number 10 were advised to have it much
lower but it's still a big political
gamble for boris johnson okay tomorrow
for now thanks very much today thank you
john bolton with us in just a moment
before that two high-ranking united
states officials will meet qatari
ministers this morning to discuss the
ongoing situation in afghanistan the
secretary of state anthony blinken and
the defense secretary lloyd austin are
in doha to meet qatar's ruling emir to
seek support for the evacuation of
americans left behind in afghanistan
they are expected to meet the qatari
ministers this morning but president
biden wouldn't be drawn on what future
relations between the u.s and
afghanistan could look like
that's a long way off thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
didn't have much to say did he let's get
the views of the former u.s national
security adviser john bolton who is with
us now in the studio good morning thank
you so much for joining us on the
program today what ramifications does
joe biden have do you think uh as a
result of the withdrawal from
afghanistan what impact is it going to
have on his presidency well i think it's
already had a very dramatic negative
impact in his favorable unfavorable
ratings that could spill over into the
domestic area this month where he has
3.5 trillion dollars that he wants to
spend but i think internationally it has
called into question his competence his
professionalism his credibility i think
the decision to withdraw was
catastrophically bad
and i think biden is suffering
accordingly wasn't his decision
originally though was it it was he was
just putting into effect a decision that
was made by president trump well look
trump bears a full share of the blame
here but biden could have changed the
policy he's changed other trump policies
biden and trump on this issue see eye to
eye they both want it out and i believe
it's both their responsibility
did the war achieve what it set out to
do
well it achieved enough of what it set
out to do it prevented another terrorist
attack like 911 for 20 years against the
united states i personally never
believed that nation building was part
of our mission i think that we had a
geostrategic
reason to be there i think we still do i
think we're now very much at risk going
forward and so is europe
you say nation building wasn't part of
the remit but but if not then what what
was going to be left behind because
we saw what happened when the russians
pulled out they pulled out uh
in 1979 1918 a 10-year war uh pulled out
in 1989 and they were basically saying
it's a failed state we need to leave so
the americans knew what it was before
they went in well the objective was to
overthrow the taliban that had given
al-qaeda aid and comfort and destroy
al-qaeda we were substantially but not
totally successful the the mission
thereafter then creating a
no but thereafter the question would be
what uh society did the afghans
themselves want to build we set about
building a strong central government i
never thought that was necessary the key
point is not to help the afghans god
bless them and all that the key point
was to protect america and its allies
from further terrorist attacks once you
get beyond that it gets very difficult
to contain the mission and that's
partially what we're suffering from now
given what's happened do you think that
america is as safe now
as it was when you went in in october of
2001. no clearly we're less safe today
we are back in the pre-911 environment
and the idea that somehow taliban of
reform they now have smiling faces
they're going to allow women and girls
to have education and careers they're
not going to do what they say they
believe in
in afghanistan i think is a mistake we
can't know for certain but the people
with the most information are the people
of afghanistan and they're terrified
about taliban we had the uk head of the
army here where you're sat a couple of
weeks ago and he said we have to take
them at their word for now the taliban i
don't take the taliban at their word for
anything i personally wouldn't give them
air to breathe
and i think we've already seen evidence
that foreign fighters have started to
come back into afghanistan al qaeda
never really left
isis k is simply another competitor with
taliban
and the idea that taliban are now more
or less on our side against isis k i
think it's a fool's errand when you say
a pre-9 11
terror threat
can you expand on that for me well it's
not there today but it may be there soon
and the the circumstances are that you
have a terrorist government uh in
afghanistan now under the taliban and as
they did before they allowed sanctuaries
to al-qaeda and other terrorist groups
that's the threat i think that we see
again and from those sanctuaries these
terrorists could plan attacks on the
united states and others so i don't see
any reason to be optimistic i think
moreover we have to look beyond just the
threat from afghanistan i think this has
had this decision to withdraw has had a
very negative effect for the u.s and
nato as a whole vis-a-vis russia
vis-a-vis china and others i think they
see this as weakness and i think they
will try to exploit it and you're
particularly worried about the situation
in pakistan yeah look uh i think now
nuclear weapons with a terrorist
government next door the the risk of a
terrorist government in pakistan
increases dramatically that risk is
already there
and if terrorists take over they've got
scores of nuclear weapons that they can
deploy around the world which is
frightening i mean you i want to just
quote you last week you uh told cnbc the
rise of the taliban in afghanistan poses
a threat of a takeover of pakistan by
terror groups it would be a catastrophe
if like-minded terror groups take
control of pakistan's nuclear weapons i
mean
that's scary stuff do you think that's a
very real threat well look i think the
united states has been concerned about
pakistani nuclear weapons whether in
onesies or twozies getting into
terrorist hands or the worst case
scenario the entire government
being taken over by terrorists look the
inner services intelligence of the
pakistani military has been paymastered
to the taliban for decades
uh that their influence their radical
influence has spread throughout the
pakistani
military which is the steel skeleton
that really governs pakistan so the
danger is already there i just think the
danger now is worth worse with a
terrorist group in charge next door
how did the west get it so wrong when it
came to withdrawing from afghanistan
because we were led to believe that
while uh the afghan army were not as
highly trained as potentially they might
be they were certainly on the right
track and they significantly outnumbered
the taliban so what went wrong was it
the intelligence that was wrong no look
i think people have misunderstood this
mission for a long time i i would never
believe that the afghan army was
america's front line of defense i mean
again i wish them well and so on or i
did because they don't exist anymore but
the real defense for america is america
and the insurance policy we had was a
relatively small military presence in
afghanistan
with a footprint for a larger
intelligence gathering operation
that we now no longer have it's better
to try and fend off the terrorists in
afghanistan than in the streets and
skies over america so why was the
decision made
because uh biden and trump together
bought the argument that they needed to
end endless wars and that there was time
for america to come home that'd be fine
if the terrorists had given up i don't
think their ideology has gotten more
moderate after 20 years in exile and
pakistan i think they have fought they
have now succeeded
why should they moderate now so it was
for a domestic audience um that they
didn't want forever wars and and
certainly the american people had
decided that 20 years was more than long
enough no i don't think the american
people decided anything i think we've
had a long time of failed leadership
obama trump and biden all of whom failed
to explain that the american people were
safer having a relatively small military
presence in afghanistan than to pull it
out for symbolic reasons and give the
territory back to the terrorists this
was a completely self-inflicted wound
but it was the symbolism of 9 11 it was
we need our troops home
before the 20th anniversary of 9 11. was
it that simple well i think in biden's
mind it was and that was purely
political there's certainly no military
reason to do it i think the uniform
advice of the pentagon and i suspect
many military figures in this country
was don't withdraw
and now there's a very
well
maintained uh army if you will of the
taliban that have got so much hardware
that was left behind by the americans
when they left
so they are quite a formidable enemy now
well i think that goes to show why the
decision to withdraw was a mistake it's
not just we're going to get our troops
back it's every other consequence that
flows from that and i think neither
trump nor biden fully analyzed it and i
think more and more implications will
become clear we've now got a situation
for us uk and others where hundreds
maybe thousands of citizens people who
worked with our military over two
decades are now hostages in afghanistan
and we will probably get them out but we
will pay dearly for it okay so we are
where we are you wouldn't start from
here as we say here in the uk what's
going to happen now or what should
happen next as far as the us is
concerned should troops go back in well
i don't think they can go back in under
biden presidency so i think what we have
to do is try to isolate the taliban if
if need be put more pressure on pakistan
not to aid terrorist groups
and be prepared to take stronger steps
against pakistan but i think these
implications go well beyond central asia
i think the people of taiwan are worried
about what china will try and do reading
this is american weakness in central and
eastern europe people there are worried
about russia the russians that's what
they're worried about and in the middle
east many of our friends in the arab
world and israel are troubled about
the implications there so i think we've
suffered a very severe setback it's
repairable but we have to look at it in
broad strategic terms this is not simply
pulling 2500 americans out of
afghanistan it's much more complicated
and much more negative but you think
abiding presidency can't afford to go
back in to afghanistan reputationally i
don't think he has the dna to go back in
i think we've got
uh we're only eight months into the
biden administration we we've got five
six of its left and and i think it's
dangerous times but there will be a big
debate in the united states over this i
think public opinion is already turning
against the withdrawal decision now that
the cost now that the consequences of
the withdrawal are clear and what about
the reputational damage for the united
states with its western allies
well i think this is again something
biden did
uh to himself after coming in and saying
i'm the professional that can clean up
after donald trump his first major
decision involving nato the withdrawal
of america and therefore nato forces he
did without any consultation whatever
with
uh with uh with the british with other
nato members uh and and this this is uh
something i think that has cost
him reputationally within nato but it's
also led to the usual calls for more
european defense capabilities that's
another mirage the european union is
something that's
for a long time been less than the sum
of its parts there's a lot of rhetoric
about defense capability very few
resources if nato is weakened by this
we're all going to be worse off
of course he was here in the uk in june
of this year at the g7 summit in
cornwall
speaking about the situation in
afghanistan he then seemed to
unilaterally make a decision to come out
of afghanistan without having that
conversation and the other g7 members
scrambled to try to speak to him right
well i i think it's hard to it's hard to
understand how biden could have made
such a mess of it as i say he bears
responsibility with trump for the
decision to withdrawal but the execution
militarily and diplomatically i think is
primarily buttons i can't let you go
without asking you about our special
relationship with the us and the uk we
hear so much about it all the time
still uh we
have reached out to the u.s and said
let's have this travel corridor let's
communicate with each other let's be
able to move around and biden is saying
nope uh and he has no plans whatsoever
to make it easier for brits to travel to
the us do we always overestimate this
special relationship and it was only
ever in place when reagan and thatcher
were in power no i think i think it's
there biden is obsessed by
uh by the coronavirus
threat i think he's reacting against
trump who dismissed it i think they're
both wrong
i think we are at a point where we
should have more travel and reciprocity
i think there are a lot of things that
need to get done i think the bilateral
trade agreement between the u.s
and the uk should be our mutual highest
priority it will benefit both of us once
we get it done
is he a one or two term president
he's a one-term president i don't think
he's going to run for re-election
question is whether he makes it through
the first term so you don't think he'll
run for re-election i do not know i
don't think well to answer your next
question i don't think trump will run in
1984 either you've been looking at my
notes
let me ask you briefly before i let you
go about uh 9 11 it is the 20th
anniversary do you remember where you
were when the planes hit and what are
you going to do to commemorate well i
was at the state department i was under
secretary of state for arms control and
international security and we were in a
meeting when the two planes hit the
world trade center i went to my office
which was on the southwest corner of the
seventh floor of the state department
and somebody ran in and said the
pentagon's been hit so i went to the
window i could see the smoke
and the flames from the pentagon and i
spent all day and all night at the state
department working through it and
i i i will commemorate it very quietly
that's all okay we appreciate you taking
the time to join us this morning great
to be with you thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you do you
remember where you were when the planes
hit well it's 20 years since al qaeda
terrors hijacked those four commercial
airliners packed with passengers and
flew them into targeted buildings in new
york
and also in washington i was on air
we believe there has been a third
hijacked of a jumbo jet
we also believe though again not
confirmed but there are reports of an
explosion at the pentagon
full coverage of the 911 attacks 20
years on from 5 p.m
on friday i'm going to be in new york
that evening and then on saturday
throughout the day the day of the
anniversary full coverage from 9 00 a.m
on saturday morning 20 years
on from 9 11.
john bolton saying that he was near the
pentagon uh and he was at his office all
day and all night where were you when
the planes hit and we will be speaking
tomorrow and the day after to one of the
first responders the first firefighter
who was on the scene um he had to make
the decision to stay in the lobby of the
north tower the first one to be hit and
to send his brother
to his death
up the stairwell
let's uh move on and uh talk about
sports should we women's tennis has a
new star 18 year old british player emma
radukanu has reached the quarterfinals
of the u.s open and is being tipped
for the top as helen and smith reports
[Applause]
undoubtedly the biggest moment in a
blossoming career
what a moment
aged just 18 through to the
quarter-finals of a u.s open in what's
only her second ever grand slam
tournament
emma rajakani's performance had a
somewhat shaky start she lost the first
two games and was love 40 down in the
third
but she fought back and then barely
looked back dropping only one more game
for the rest of the match
to take the opening set
watched on by legends of the game billie
jean king and virginia wade who won here
in 1968 her win decisive her delight
self-evident
thank you so much for watching my match
uh i really appreciate it and you're an
absolute legend so i'm really honored to
have had you here
it's been an astonishing run for the
teenager despite seven matches and three
top 50 opponents she hasn't even lost a
set
but as success and popularity mount so
too does the pressure
she faced scrutiny earlier this summer
when she withdrew from the fourth round
of wimbledon she was a wild card it was
her first grand slam and there were
suggestions it had all got too much
a return like this say some shows
exceptional resilience
i really believe that we've got um a
female tennis player british tennis
player that will go on to win grand
slams and indeed be a future world
number one however we need to be mindful
that she's you know emma's still very
young and 18. but her next match will no
doubt be harder belinda benchitch is
olympic champion but for now this moment
is for savouring
by any measure a sensation or summer in
a career has only just started
helen smith sky news in washington
fantastic news now planet super league
and counters in have joined forces to
launch cup 26 a football tournament
encouraging fans children and families
to take action against climate change
with us now is the founder of planet
super league and that's tom griffin
hello to you mr griffin thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
what is cup 26
morning kay we launched cup 26 to try
and inspire
football fans and people all over the
country to do their bit for climate
change
and what we do is we partner with
football clubs we've got 49 of them that
we're launching the season with today
and we invite their fans to sign up and
represent their club and play for the
planet and what fans can do is
they go to our platform and there's a
whole bunch of activities they can do
that um have some fun and help them
reduce their carbon footprint get
together as a family so it could be a
meat-free meal or and have a screen free
evening or line dry your clothes and
they score goals every time they take
these actions and the goals help their
team in matches much like football match
and the tournament lasts for seven weeks
and just as cop begins we'll know um
which fans are the greenest and which
club wins
which clubs have signed up
there's all sorts of clubs so
importantly mk your club wigan are
signed up so um i hope you'll be signing
up to play for them but we've got spurs
and liverpool and arsenal and chelsea
and chesterfield and northampton and
lincoln city and my club nottingham
forest so there's over half of the clubs
in the country are signed up so um if
any of you are fans of um these clubs
please go to
cup26.co.uk and sign up and play for
your club
okay and how do you decide who wins
so it's very much like a football match
each week your um your club plays a
fixture against another club and the
match lasts a week in length not 90
minutes because we want to give people
time to have their meet free meals or or
walk to work or whatever it may be so
over that week um whenever you take an
action you score a goal or two or three
and it's live on the site so there's a
sort of live scoreboard and they kick
off on a monday morning and on the
sunday evening we know who the winner of
that match is
and the winner gets three points and
it's the draw they get a point and much
like say the euros there's a and the we
start with group stages so there's nine
groups um and then the winners of those
go into a semis and then we have a final
amazing look forward to it come back
please and tell us um who wins and how
they've got on how they did manage to
take the trophy i'm guessing there is a
trophy
there is a trophy this is the trophy
that we're at
there we go fantastic lovely with west
ham colors are they aston villa colors
they're actually burnley
they're
burnley are the current title holders so
three colors oh okay aleister campbell
will be pleased it's good to talk to you
thanks very much for joining us thank
you
[Music]
now a bit of heartwarming news a
three-year-old boy has been found safe
and well in australia after being
missing for three days on his own
in woodland video footage shows aj l
flack who has autism and doesn't speak
sitting in a creek while cupping water
into his hands to drink and there he is
bless his cotton socks the crew of a
police helicopter spotted him in the
creek on monday morning three days after
he went missing from his family's remote
remote i should say rural property he
was dehydrated not surprisingly had
nappy rash but was otherwise well but
was taken to hospital for observation
his family are simply overjoyed as you
can imagine to see him back good for him
that is amazing like to end with some
happy news for you coming up in the next
hour social care the government says
they're going to reform it how they're
going to pay for it stay tuned and find
out
[Music]